from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between kit kats in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
in japan our kitkats come in four sizes
big little pouch bite
and bar
and classy one sublime so one thing to
note here regarding mini sizes the
regular kitkat is 11.6 grams but the
flavored minutes such as matcha are said
to be slightly smaller 11.3 grams so i'm
gonna wet them now to confirm so let's
weigh a regular flavor kitkat first
it weighs 11 grams but it doesn't show
the decimal points is it just 11 grams
that's way
much matcha flavor
12. it's actually heavier than regular
flavor interesting japanese kitkats have
become popular all around the world in
the u.s of course is no exception i just
want to mention the top here we're going
to be talking about kitkats that are
native to our countries i know you can
get them online i think walmart.com has
some of them fantastic they're imported
we know thank you in the u.s our kitkats
come in nine sizes starting from the
smallest we have a kitkat minis
unwrapped then the fins miniatures snack
size standard forefinger the big cat
from there we move up to
king size which is a piece accidentally
broke off and then i accidentally ate it
the big cat king size this looks like
just be two big cats and the biggest
size the xl
a bag of kitkat bites should have 11
bites let's count in japanese
each sound c
and according to the bag
the combined weight should be 50 grams
so let's weigh all 11 bites
it weighs
52 grams good deal
all of our u.s sizes come in a variety
of units depending on your kitkat needs
so many varieties here's a few worth
mentioning the minis the biggest bag of
minis unwrapped you can get is
grams as a title implies
these things are unwrapped little bites
it's sold like it's for sharing but get
real whoever sticks their hand in here
first it's their bag for the miniatures
according to amazon you can get up to
four pound bags aka 1814.37
grams and what it looks like they just
sent me
a bag that's loosely four pounds of
kitkat minis all the bars have their
various packs none of them seem unusual
i will however mention that the biggest
single purchase of a kitkat item you can
get is the king-size 24-pack the total
here is 2040 grams about 4.5
pounds of kit kat
here's all the kit-kats exclusive to the
us and here is all the kitkats native to
japan kitkat in japan is made by nestle
and is one of the best selling candies
in the country one of the reasons for
its popularity is that kitkat has a good
luck charm in japan because the name
kitkat in japanese is kitpokato and
kittokato sounds like
which means you will surely win so the
kitkat brand became associated with good
luck and these kitkats are often given
to students before their exams for the
past 10 years kitkat has introduced more
than 350 unique flavors wow some of them
are discontinued unfortunately and some
of them are original so we could get
them by the filming of this episode
so here are a few standard kitkat
flavors in japan coffee break but it
doesn't taste like coffee but goes well
with coffee
so i brought my coffee with me today so
let's see how it goes
it's actually pretty good much better
than expected so next we have
melon
it's so melon it has way too strong
melon flavor next we have chocolate
orange
overall not bad next graham cracker
this is fantastic next i'm gonna go
cheesecake
this is marvellous if you're a
cheesecake person like me you will
definitely like this next strawberry
cheesecake
you get some decent strawberry flavor
and cheesecake flavor at the same time
which is amazing next apple cinnamon
i'm no big fan of this there's a lot of
cinnamon in it which makes this horrible
pistachio look at this cute squirrel
kawaii
it's not great but not horrible either
next pudding
it's disgusting
it's way too sweet let's go next one we
have strawberry milk
holy crap
this is nasty
this is the worst one
so this is the last one i've got cookies
and cream
this is the best thing i've ever had in
my mouth
sorry to interrupt but believe it or not
the us does have a few exclusive flavors
you can't get in japan first up
pumpkin pie
yo this is exactly like pumpkin pie yeah
they hit it out of the park with that
one wow ki lime pie
this one's so good it tastes just like
key lime pie these are both fantastic
fruity cereal
what's what cereal is this is that fruit
loops tastes exactly like fruit loops
gingerbread
raspberry cream
i love this one yo joe
really
all right try it let's go what do you
guys think
yeah yeah starburst good call witch's
brew crispy wafers and marshmallow
flavored cream
you look great yeah it has like um a
frosting flavor to it i got uh glow in
the dark
wait what's supposed to glow in the dark
the packaging or the that's not fun i
thought this was going to glow in the
dark
the packaging let's see it let's give it
a shot
nothing's glowing all right lights back
on little red little quick crop
there's a regular how disappointing your
thumbs down
birthday cake
clothes like a frosting and sprinkles
flavor man they're all really good also
in the u.s you get a lemon crisp flavor
sold out everywhere it was like a
supreme drop
the second those hit the shelves are
gone also kitkat in the us has this line
called duo's
as you can see
three different flavors two flavors in
one we've got mint and dark chocolates
they're just like thin mints mocha and
chocolate eh i'm already i'm not
predicting this is gonna be anything
special
strawberry and dark chocolate is the way
i'm eating these annoying
i mean it's not terrible but the
strawberry and chocolate have been too
sweet with a dark chocolate into it so
these were fun right these were fun no
all right back to japan kitkat has a
collection of flavors inspired by the
many regions and prefectures of japan so
i'm gonna start with this mont fuji the
highest mountain in japan it's
3776 meters high and the flavor is
strawberry cheesecake flavor how can i
open this
here we go it looks great
it's pretty good but it tastes exactly
the same as the one that i tasted 10
minutes ago
alright next one is this
shinshu apple shinshu is kind of very
all the way to called nagano prefecture
and nagano prefecture is located in the
center of japan and is famous for
delicious apples and finally they turn
into kitkats
oh
this is the nicest chocolate i've ever
had next we have amaul strawberry so
it's basically from kyushu kyushu is
japan's third largest island and is
located southwest of japan and amaul is
the best brand of strawberries in japan
marvelous again next i'm going to go
with this one ito kyuemon ujimacha and
he
are named after uji city where they are
grown and the difference between matcha
and hojicha is moja is material much as
a green tea but hojicha is a roasted
green tea let's go with fuji matcha
first
matcha is always perfect how about
hojicha
it's as beautiful as my heart let's move
on to the next one we have benimo benimo
which is purple sweet potato it's from
okinawa so okinawa is japan's
southernmost prefecture and is famous
for benimo okinawa is my favorite place
in japan
i love this he has just right sweetness
we've got azuki sandwich flavor from
nagoya so nagoya is located in between
tokyo and osaka and it's famous for its
azuki sandwich azuki is sweet red bean
paste so sweet red bean paste sandwich
it's not my taste at all momiji manju
flavor it's from hiroshima so hiroshima
is located in the southwest of japan and
is famous for its momiji manju which is
kind of maple leaf shaped cake filled
with sweet bean paste
it tastes exactly the same as this one
sweet red bean paste japanese people
love sweet red bean paste hokkaido azuki
and strawberry flavor hokkaido is the
largest and northernmost prefecture in
japan and it's famous for its azuki
better than the other azuki flavors
why wasabi and it's from shizuoka and
shizuoka is located along the pacific
coast and is the top wasabi producing
region in japan
believe it or not it's actually pretty
good
let's go this one strawberry cheesecake
flavor again
it's from yokohama yokohama is located
next to tokyo but yokohama is not famous
for strawberry cheesecake i don't know
why they chose strawberry cheesecake
flavor for this
it tastes exactly the same same
next we have tokyo banana so tokyo
banana is a banana shaped sponge cake
with cream filling and it is very
popular souvenir of tokyo and they turn
into
cat cats
ta-da
it's gross when you come to tokyo you
should try poke bananas but you should
not try but talk about that kitkat rum
raisin
it's from
tokyo tokyo is not famous for ram racing
but says ramirez's gorgeousness and
fastness matches the image of tokyo
[Music]
there is a sort of rum i don't like it
it contains a lot of alcohol
last one sake flavor which is a japanese
traditional alcohol made from rice this
is a really interesting one
personally i like it and this is like an
acquired taste so when it comes to sake
flavor we were supposed to have yogurt
sake yuzu sake limited edition japan
sake umeshu but these were not available
at the time of filamentous and we have
kit kat desserts we have kitkat
colliders which i cannot find in the
filming of this but it looks to be
almost like vanilla flavored cups with
kitkat chunks broken up in it
oh man i had too much too many kitkats
and then we have these
these kitkats ice cream cones
i i hit a wall real hard
and a giant kit kat xl wall and i want i
officially did not want to do this
anymore
better but not by much more yeah so
that's it for the u.s sorry we have so
few flavors japan has a kitkat called
otonano amassa which translates to
sweetness for adults
don't let your kids watch this part
alright so it's a line of kitkat flavors
that are a little more bitter and less
with the regular kitkats so here we have
otona masa strawberry
white
and dark matcha
and dark chocolate right so let's give
it a try first this is just straight up
dark chocolate as you can imagine
strawberry
ooh
it's actually tart this is good all
right so let's move on to the next one
we've got dark matcha
this is so deep
much deeper than the other matter
flavors
so last one we've got otonano amazon
white chocolate
this is the best one among these otona
masa chocolates just right sweetness
alright so let's do matcha taste test
in japan matcha flavored kitkats are so
popular over the years we've introduced
13 different different different
different matcha flavors but currently
we were only able to get these three so
let's see how different they are first
dark matcha
deep matcha
was also deep ito among ujimacha
so freaking hard to tell the difference
but i'd say this one is the most
delicious one kyoto
we can get it in kyoto or order online
so here we have classy chocolates called
sublime so we have white sublime
and raw milk sublime and a volcanic
green sublime and orange volcanic sub
rhyme yellow ruby sublime alright so
let's try some out i'm getting sick of
the sweetness
it doesn't taste anything i was thinking
that you know like it tastes like
strawberry or raspberry or something but
did i get coffee confident
okay let's keep going all right so i'm
gonna go yellow volcanic volcano
this is the bitterest i've got orange
bitter
now i'm so scared green
sublime
it tastes exactly same as this too so
bitter next we have
milk sublime
it tastes exactly the same as regular
flavor i prefer this one last one i've
got white sublime
compared to the oto nanoamazon white
chocolate it's much better i'm done
hey guys it's harry i can't let you do a
kick episode without me because kitkats
were actually invented in the uk in
1935. they would eventually be
distributed by nestle across the uk the
eu and japan but in the u.s kitkats are
made and distributed by hershey's if you
watched our snickers episode you'll know
that there are some major taste
differences between the chocolate in the
uk and the us mostly that the uk's is
way better i'm do a three-way taste test
between uk us and also a japanese kitkat
to see if there's any major differences
between the three and harry thank you
for sending me this with your cute
handwriting thank you hari i get though
let's try uk kitkat first
the uk one is obviously the one i'm used
to the chocolate is very smooth not
overwhelmingly sweet and just very tasty
the uk is already like a lot richer
[Music]
okay okay can i try usb kitkat i also
couldn't find just a standard american
kitkat anywhere i guess we didn't bother
importing the regular one the closest
thing i could find was this kitkat duo's
mocha and chocolate one
something doesn't taste quite right
about that nope
uk
u.s they suck they both have too much
sugar joe harry try japan's kitchen
much smoother creamier in terms of
picking your favorite i think the us one
gets discounted immediately then between
the uk and the japan one it's kind of a
different style of kitkat i guess i
would say japan and uk are pretty neck
and neck they seem very similar japan's
kitkat is the best in the world
not eating too much candy
perhaps we can pinpoint the taste
difference to the ingredients in the u.s
a kitkat is made up of sugar wheat flour
our kitkats have the following
looking over the ingredients i noticed
our kitkats have cocoa butter and
chocolate although it does not specify
what that chocolate is made up of do we
assume it is the same as the hershey's
chocolate bar i don't know whereas the
japan kitkat has cocoa mass cocoa butter
and cocoa powder now we're to believe
that nestle in japan holds their
chocolate to the same standards they do
in the uk it would mean that it would
have a higher fat and cocoa content
according to the uk rules a product must
contain no less than 25 coca salads to
be considered milk chocolate u.s
definitely does not go by this rule our
kitkat is made up of palm oil where
theirs is vegetable oil same in the uk
it is cheaper but is also worse in the
environment adding to deforestation
increasing greenhouse emissions and
water pollution so it is bad in the
environment and tastes worse fantastic
but good news for all you vegans nestle
has created a vegan kitkat with
substituted milk with a rice based
alternative but availability is
currently limited so they are not
available in the us or japan
this is a us kitkat miniature and is 8.5
grams the closest size we have the
japan's mini this is 42 calories 2.2
grams of fat 6 milligrams of sodium 5.8
grams of carbs four of those are sugar
and one gram of protein in japan the
mini is the most popular size it's 62
calories and 3.5 grams of fat 3.5 to
11.4 milligrams of sodium 8.99 to 19.4
grams of total carbs and 0.9 grams of
protein the most common kitkat size in
the u.s is the four finger bar 210
calories 11 grams of fat seven of those
are saturated 20 milligrams of sodium 28
grams of carbs 23 of those are sugar and
2 grams of protein the closest size we
have do that in japan is the kitkat bar
it contains 224 calories the most
calorie kitkat in the us we got is the
kitkat xl now i unwrapped it here so you
can see just how big it is it contains
640 calories the most calories you will
get in a kitkat in japan is the big
little pouch bite this bag is
275 calories
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between burger king and japan and the
u.s this is food wars
here's everything you can find on the
menu of the burger king in japan but not
in the u.s
here's everything you can find at a u.s
burger king you cannot get in japan all
right so let's start with exclusive
burgers so here we have
teriyaki lettuce burger and teriyaki
whopper
cute
next we have
avocado salad burger and avocado whopper
a little cute baby
look at this
and
whopper
it's totally different
this one is so huge
and avocados tomato no tomatoes i don't
know why
next we have cuatro cheese whopper
big boy
[Applause]
we've got smoky barbecue whopper
and smoky barbecue whopper junior and
here is
spicy whopper
it's hot sauce
next we have
tattered chicken burger
it's got
a lot of tartar sauce chicken crispy
burger king in japan just released a
brand new burger called guilty burger
it's basically butter burger
why what have you done
let's check out this guilty butter beef
burger first the bun is different
itadakimasu
just a little bit of butter flavor but i
don't feel as guilty as he claims this
one is guilty butter crockett sandwich
[Music]
guilty
and
here is guilty butter chicken burger
first one is something that bk has
excluded oh my god
this is called the texas whopper
[Laughter]
two patties cheese bacon bunch of
veggies wait for it
the triple whopper look at the size of
this thing the weight of it has
completely flattened the bottom bun and
there's nothing between
the patties of meat
what the hell are you guys doing over
there next
uh no the bacon king oh my god looks to
be a
pretty bacon-centric looks like a double
whopper with cheese bacon male ketchup
mustard they didn't mess with the
veggies thank you you're not fooling
anyone getting lettuce and an onion on
that one the rodeo burger is a little
guy with onion rings the rodeo burger
yeehaw onto the chicken
japan does not have what we call the
original chicken sandwich and i don't
know why burger king maybe just to set
itself apart the chicken sandwich is
this like sub shape right this is like
it's like i'm holding the phone this is
great chicken junior spicy chicken
junior let's go
spicy barely registers on the spice
meter wait
yeah bks in the us have something called
the chick king sandwich you can get the
sandwich regular or deluxe you can also
get the sandwich flavor regular or spicy
so here is the regular regular and as
you can see just comes with sauce and
pickles and the chicken you can get it
deluxe and spicy so we went with deluxe
comes with all these veggies that you
brush off when you start eating it
and it is got a spicy kind of hue to the
chicken there here is our salad menu
let's start with this one
we've got hot dog
it's got such a big
sausage this one is chili beans hot dog
and next we have this little guy
snack chicken
unless we have
this one
chili cheese fries
and if you want some veggies you can
order caesar salad
but my bad i forgot to order
also exclusives to the us are these
chicken fries as you can tell they look
like fries but they're pieces of chicken
no babe
you can get mozza applesauce
jalapeno cheddar bites i've never heard
of these
and now i know why
burger king in the u.s has two iced
coffee flavors mocha and vanilla
assuming that's the mocha
it's exactly like chocolate milk
no oh the aftertaste is horrible what
the hell that's ridiculous how bad that
is and the vanilla
that is that is so sweet
i'm gonna keep this one
so here is our dessert menus here we
have coffee float
a little bit melting sorry and we have
melon soda float
coke float and coke zero float
and here we've got
premium sundae chocolate and coffee
and here is our chocolate sundae and
strawberry sundae
and my favorite is
this apple pie
desserts here in the using yourself a
hershey's sunday pie
this one might have uh got a little
roughed up in transit and in the us
burger king you can also get various
shakes
here we have oreo shake a chocolate oreo
shake a chocolate shake and a vanilla
shake all right
god that's so good the straight up
chocolate
oh man this is trouble
wow burger king shakes are really good
i'm assuming this is just the straight
oreo one
oh my god
this is fantastic
are we all curious what a chocolate oreo
shake tastes like
wonder no more
good this one's the best also us burger
king you can get a soft serve cone i
didn't get it only because
we have no refrigeration unit here and
it would just be a cone with a puddle of
ice cream so victoria please turn me
into a giant soft serve cone
so here are our drinks let's start with
this one this one is ginger
and fanta melon
oolong tea
which is chinese tea
and orange juice
and this one is
earl grey iced tea
next we have darjeeling tea
and here is
calpis
which you guys call it
kyle piccol in your country in japan we
say
i know it sounds like
in english but if you say calpico to
japanese people they will never
understand what you're talking about so
in japan once again we say karupi su
repeat after me
karupi
very good
first things you can get you can get a
little orange juice guy
and you can also get
capri-sun apple juice shout out to the
pouch burger king in the u.s has coke
products as well but we have something
called a coke freestyle machine if you
haven't seen this big machine that has a
bunch of uh coca-cola related beverages
you can mix and match them anyway we can
get high c fruit punch high c pink
lemonade fanta orange mellow yellow
powerade zero dr pepper barks diet barks
you can also get yourself a fat free
milk
there it is sweetened or unsweetened tea
i think i got the sweetened i don't want
any tea
tea sucks we also have something called
frozen cokes that is this right here as
you can see it's been sitting for a
while starting to separate we have
frozen coke you also have a frozen fanta
wild cherry a frozen phantom blue
raspberry and a frozen strawberry
lemonade
oh yeah japan has a few exclusives that
are similar but different to that in the
u.s so for example this is our
plant-based popper
this burger is made from 100
soy beans
it's actually delicious i like it
when it comes to vegetarianism and
veganism they are not that popular in
japan but gradually especially the
restaurants in tokyo are offering more
vegan or vegetarian meals because there
is more japanese people and non-japanese
people were vegan or vegetarian compared
to other places in japan but overall the
vegan or vegetarian option is still
limited in japan and in the u.s we have
the impossible whopper what's the
difference well the impossible burger
has all these ingredients so as you can
see a lot more
i am curious
well it looks like meat right
tastes act like a whopper i don't think
i would notice the difference they're
covering the lack of meat with like with
that shower flavor that they have in
there
no that's good
in japan we call this burger crispy
chicken burger
and the us we have the before mentioned
chick king sandwich which comes in
varieties of spicy and or deluxe
for breakfast our hash brown comes in
one big piece
whereas in the us
our hash browns come in little bites and
in japan we have this
cheese bites
look at this
and in the u.s we have eight-piece
cheesy tots well
and on to the us breakfast exclusives as
you can see we have a lot more going on
in our breakfast menu here in the u.s
than japan has here in the u.s you can
get your breakfast sandwich and biscuit
or crew sandwich options chris sandwich
is of course a croissant sandwich took
those two words put them together for
sandwich so we have
bacon egg and cheese
ham egg and cheese
and
sausage and cheese
we have two breakfast burritos the
eggnormis
breakfast burrito which i'm assuming is
this one because it is
enormous
the breakfast burrito junior look at
this little guy
french toast sticks who doesn't like
french toast
finally pancake platter with just three
pancakes or a pancake platter with three
pancakes and a side of sausage
[Music]
the fries at burger king in japan come
in three sizes small
medium
and large
fries in the u.s at burger king come in
four sizes value small medium or large
or maybe it's value small medium large
does this look right any of you food
wars heads would have seen the burger
king us versus uk episode where we
uncovered fry gates two sizes had pretty
much the exact same unit of fries now as
you can see from these i can't tell
which is the value in the small i'm
assuming this is the medium well
unfortunately we cannot do
that amazingly accurate scientific test
that we did in the last episode because
the fries have been compromised they all
came in the same bag
and i think they knew what we were up to
and they purposely dumped all the fries
in the same bag to contaminate the
experiments you've outsmarted us this
time let's wait a large price to see how
much you actually get
151 grams what if we did a thing where
like whatever lands and stays on counts
counts does that seem like a fair thing
to say
that's really smart what i just did
there i think
to 195 grams
let's weigh japan's whopper
250 grams and let us weigh our whopper
in the us
yeah
270 yeah 270 grams so pretty cool
surprisingly close
if you're not feeling like having beef
burger king also has some chicken
options you can order your chicken
nuggets in five pieces and eight pieces
here in the us you can get your nuggets
in sizes of four pieces eight pieces or
16 pieces and it's worth noting that you
can only get the 16 piece online or
through their app and even if you do
they still just give you two eight
pieces i don't know why either
so let's weigh 8-piece nuggets
130 grams
divided by 8
equals
16.25 grams
per nugget i don't know if we can get as
accurate of a measurement for something
so small so we will use
this guy instead
so i'll just do this
and put the scale up here
ah
this is a bad idea eight pieces is uh
104 grams
divided by
eight
is
13 grams
in japan we have three drink sizes small
and medium
and large
in the us we have four drink sizes value
which only comes with the value meal
small medium and large now i want to
note that the us's largest drink size is
112 percent larger than japan's largest
drink
now what's the biggest meal you can get
in japan's burger king over here it's
the king
meal
the king meal ranges anywhere from 790
to 990 yen depending on the burger you
choose it has your choice of an avocado
whopper double cheeseburger or whopper
we chose the double cheeseburger which
comes with small fries
five piece nuggets
medium coke and apple pie
and in the us currently our single
biggest menu item at a burger king is
the 30 ultimate party bundle now you can
only order this party bundle through the
bk app and it includes two whoppers two
double cheeseburgers two original
chicken sandwiches two eight piece
chicken nuggets four small fries and
four small drinks and it costs
thirty dollars
in japan a whopper cheese set it costs
around 890 yen or 7.80 us
where is in the us the same meal with a
small frying drink is
9.29 or 1059.65
japanese yen what about the medium if
you get that the medium fry and medium
drink it's ten dollars and twenty nine
cents or one thousand one hundred and
seventy three point seventy one japanese
yen
what about the large
poof hey there it is right in front of
me large fries and drink
11.29 or 1287.78
japanese yen
let's look at calories in japan a
whopper is 676 calories the calories
aren't too bad but watch out for the
sodium levels one japan whopper is
113 of your daily recommended amount of
sodium
too much
in the u.s our whopper is 667 calories
both whoppers are pretty comparable in
most of the categories but there's one
statistic that really stands out the
salt content the sodium level in japan's
whopper is
122 percent higher than that in the us
let's make that a meal a whopper with
large fries and a large coke is
1323 calories
and the same meal in the u.s is 1
680 calories so a lot more now a big
portion of the calories actually come
from the large coke the us's is roughly
182 percent more calories than that of
japan's let's look at the highest
calorie sandwich at japan's burger king
the double whopper cheese is here eating
one of these is already half of your
daily calories and a little over your
daily recommended protein the main thing
to watch out for here is the sodium
which is 152 of your daily recommended
volume whereas in the us our highest
calorie sandwich is the spicy chick king
deluxe sandwich seen here if you're
worried about your health steer clear
this one the fat content is 190 percent
your daily allowance and the sodium is
over 200
of your daily allowance
yikes
as i mentioned earlier the biggest menu
item is the king meal if you get it with
a double bacon cheeseburger the total
calories are 1 329
that's 66 of your daily calories and of
course the 30 ultimate party bundle
which is 8 903 calories or
445
your daily caloric allowance
[Music]
burger king in japan doesn't disclose
the exact ingredients but it does
disclose where the ingredients come from
and where they're finished processing
for example the whopper beef patties are
sourced from australia new zealand and
europe but they are processed in
australia japan and austria
burger king in the us is pretty vague
when it comes to its ingredients they
don't disclose a comprehensive list
anywhere at the end of 2020 burger king
permanently banned 120 artificial
flavors from their menu including
aluminum yellows 1 through 5 bha and bht
here's the complete list
it was actually a lot of stuff
good for you guys
from calorie icon to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between wendy's in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
in japan our wendy's hamburgers come in
four sizes
junior
single double and triple
in the u.s our burgers come in four
sizes junior dave single dave's double
and the dave's triple look at the size
of this thing
in japan our nuggets come in orders of 5
and 10.
our us nuggets come in 4
6 and 10 piece our wendy's drinks come
in three sizes small medium and large
and in the u.s we also have three drink
sizes small medium you've got to be
kidding me look at the size of this
thing this might be 40 ounces julie only
one way to find out
oh
oh
not quite 40. it's about 36 or 37 fluid
ounces of coca-cola how big is a bladder
this looks like more than like i would
normally pee in the morning okay let's
measure our large
drink
it measures exactly
500 milliliters
our wendy's fries come in two sizes
small and medium our fries come in four
sizes junior
small
medium
large let's wear our largest
roughly 180 grams
it weighs
135 grams japan's chili comes in two
sizes medium and large
and the u.s our chili comes in two sizes
small and large
let us weigh the largest now
including the paper cup
430 grams let's weigh our large chili
265 grams
in japan a wendy's burger usa double is
730 yen or
6.38 cents a width our us dave's double
goes for 5.99 or around 685 japanese yen
that's a 6.6
decrease in price in the u.s let's make
it a meal in japan if you get your
burger as i said it includes a small
fries and a three-piece nuggets and a
drink it costs around 440 yen more our
meals only include fries and drink so a
small dave's double meal and i threw in
a four piece because we don't have a
three piece works out to 10.98
that's an 8.12 increase cost in the us
mind you we did get an extra nugget
speaking of nuggets in japan tempest
nugget is 500 yen which breaks down to
51 yen per nugget in the u.s a 10-piece
nugget is 429 which makes it per nugget
around 43 cents so per nugget average
the us is paying 8.11 percent less a
bacon a double in japan is 850 yen or
7.43 centi widths in the us you get that
same baconator for 7.49
or
857 japanese yen so close only a .82
percent increase
here is everything you can get at the
wendy's in japan you cannot get in the
us
and here's everything in the u.s wendy's
you can't get in japan
one thing i want to point out is that in
japan wendy's is known as wendy's first
kitchen
first kitchen is a japanese fast food
chain then it was acquired by wendy's in
2016 and became a hybrid of wendy's and
first kitchen's venues and we call them
[ __ ]
which is the abbreviation of first
kitchen in a japanese way it's like
first kitchen safa and kitchen's ki and
and say [ __ ]
repeat after me [ __ ]
got it buddy
very good so here are our japan's
exclusive burgers so this one is bacon
mushroom melt
and this one is just mushroom milk
we have wendy's bacon neck burger
we also have wendy's cheese bacon egg
burger and this sauce
tatters us
everybody's curious what this is this
one is
wild rock
it's got no buns it's got two beef
patties i think i should try this one
this meat itself has a good taste and
some kind of like peppery flavor
but
it's a little bit dry i wouldn't get
this again
and last things we have junior teriyaki
burger and we have junior teriyaki
cheeseburger
the big bacon cheeseburger
the big bacon double look at this yep
one two three the big bacon triple i
mean i don't know what what what angle
it's best to look at this at
and then we got big bacons on the fancy
bread this must be the big bacon's
classics's
this looks like
a big bacon looks like shredded cheese
and stuff on this everything's baking
something with these guys
at this point it's just like how many
slabs of meat do you want on your bacon
sandwich two things you can get at a
wendy's in the u.s
cannot get in japan or just the
junior burger and the junior
cheeseburger
look at this little guy look at this
literally every fast food burger place
has a version of this
chicken
the astiago chicken sandwiches we got
the asiago chicken
ranch classic club i said that in the
wrong order but you get what i mean
probably this one this is the fried
asiago club with bacon and then there is
the
spicy which i'm assuming is this one
and then they got
the grilled
that's pretty good
don't like astiago
when this has you covered so many
chicken sandwiches at wendy's that of
course are not asiagoed this is the
grilled chicken sandwich as you can see
it is grilled and then we have the
grilled chicken big bacon man they got
me once they've gotten some deal on on
bacon for wendy's everything's got bacon
on it i'm going to go ahead and assume
this is the big bacon fried chicken
sandwich
because it has bacon on it
say the spicy big bacon cheddar chicken
in japan our wendy's have pasta which
were originally on the first kitchen
menu so here we have ramen style soy
cream pasta with spinach and ham it
expires
2023
january 20th
joe i'll keep this for you
now that guy can go ahead and throw that
out
and next we have ramen style tan tongue
soup pasta with spinach and ham so tan
tan soup is kind of like a spicy chili
flavored soup with miso and pork mince
tan tan soup and panta ramen are very
popular in japan tomato sauce pasta
with mozzarella
and bacon
all right next we have
beef chick white cream spaghetti
plastic
next we have carbonara spaghetti
it's got bacon and this creamy
carbonara sauce
last thing i have is
spicy cardero spaghetti so spicy cuadro
in japanese is men taiko and mentaiko
spaghetti is also very popular in japan
unfortunately some americans i know
don't like men taiko so much because of
the texture and smell but for me
mentaiko is super
[ __ ] delicious
it's been a while
since i got this one it's been like
three hours
joe
tried it out i appreciate the offer
george but you can go ahead and finish
that because it looks [ __ ] disgusting
we got salads over here on this end the
first one looks like we got the parmesan
caesar salad comes with of course caesar
dressing and what looks to be parmesan
crisps this next salad is ridiculous
we're going to go ahead and put quotes
around salad wendy's has a taco salad
that comes with tortilla chips sour
cream
signature salsa
and that wasn't enough chili
before we continue you confirm that the
taco salad is supposed to have chili on
it
they told you that
chips all around here
i can't believe this this is so gross
signature salsa
then chili
oh it smells so bad
oh god
i'm just this is just like eating chili
with tortilla chips they said there's
some salt i'm just pushing this around
onto the next salad the southwest
avocado salad
oh my god there's bacon on it that's
weird that was in dave thomas's obituary
i want everything to be covered in bacon
but yeah chicken avocado bacon cheese
and some sauce this makes sense and the
last salad
apple pecan salad that smells oh because
it's like a blue cheese on it roasted
pecan bits pomegranate vinaigrette
apples are nice it's kind of nice to get
a little bit of actual like fruit
something nutritious while doing this
it's like my body's like what is this
so here are our japan-style menu we have
a few flavor options for fries so we
have healthy butter flavored fries
happy butter flavor
it has just subtle buttery flavor
burnt butter soy sauce flavor
rip it off
i don't know what's going on here but
it's pretty good much better than this
savory steamed potato butter
it gets quite strong buttery flavor
definitely i prefer this one than the
happy butter flavor this is not happy
this one is
chicken consummate flavor
mmm
this is the best fries i've ever had in
my life now i'm going to introduce you
this spicy
chicken
breast
wendy's in the us also has baked
potatoes see what we got so of course
there's your
regular and this one oh yeah this one's
got like chives and stuff in it if i was
to stop here you would go wow what a
tasteful selection of healthy potatoes
but of course we don't stop here we move
on to absolute
baked potato madness ah number one
cheese baked potato drowned this thing
in cheese it's like it's like oh it's
like cake to the side
[Music]
[Laughter]
the chili and cheese baked potato
yeah
if you are like me
you're wondering yourself something's
missing something
is missing
from this potato menu yuli can you guess
what that is the bacon cheese baked
potato oh i got big pieces of bacon this
one too
oh you get spicy chicken nuggets yes
siri bob
seasoned potatoes
all right some fruit finally made the
menu apple slices it wouldn't be a
wendy's category without the baconator
fries we need the bacon meter in this
episode last of the sides
oh yeah
oatmeal bar looks like a cliff bar
well it's actually pretty good
so here are our japan's exclusive drinks
we have tapioca royal milky with brown
sugar and tapioca milk with brown sugar
tornado
[Music]
this is amazing
simply amazing i love this so here are
other drinks we have pepsi
orange juice
and ginger ale
lemonade and melon soda
peach tea and iced tea ice matcha and
this one is iced cocoa
so here we have our hot drinks
we have
darjeeling tea
and we have coffee mocha
and we have peach tea
[Music]
i like this and we have coffee latte
and cocoa
and
matcha
this is matcha but it looks like
water from 100 years ago
our wendy's has frosty chinos which i'm
assuming are frosties meat frappuccinos
frosty chinos but it does not appear
that there's frosties in this
they have two flavors vanilla and
chocolate
assuming this is the vanilla wendy's is
smart on this one it isn't that it isn't
that sweet i was expecting it to be like
undrinkable but it's actually kind of
nice all right this one is the chocolate
yeah also
it's a nice flavor because the frosted
chinos you know what that means
wendy's you can also get oh yeah
frosties they don't have these in japan
i feel like this is the staple menu item
i love these so much
fantastic that's fantastic that's
fantastic i gotta go for the chocolate
don't buy the fundamental spoon i'm just
gonna do a taste here it's great
the brushes are great it's like a
milkshake but it's super thick and
delicious japan
you want this yeah thick it is thick
in japan we have floats instead of
frosties we have coke float and melon
soda float
japan has an exclusive breakfast
sandwich
it's called the breakfast sandwich
it's got tomato lettuce
and
i believe this is beef or pork patties
okay whereas japan has one exclusive
breakfast sandwich we have way more like
all the fast food here in america we
take our breakfast very seriously you
can get yourself a maple bacon croissant
it looks like it's a chicken sandwich
that of course has bacon and maple syrup
on the croissant uh we have what just
appears to be the bacon biscuit bacon
egg
cheese in the incredibly dry biscuits
bacon croissant i don't know about this
one moving on to the sausage zone of the
wendy's breakfast this is the special
sausage biscuit no no no no here's what
i hate about this pick a dryer thing to
have for breakfast i feel like it'd be
impossible to swallow a bite of this
you're gonna choke on it
here we go see this is what i'm talking
about they might have gotten this
backwards this is actually the better
sausage one this at least has a better
chance of not getting stuck in your
throat the sausage croissants
also has egg thank you they have a few
things that are honey butter based i am
so glad that fast food places are
introducing honey to the breakfast menu
i think maybe it's to do with the fact
that chicken sandwiches have become so
popular first one we got here is the
honey butter biscuit
hey it's just a biscuit with honey
butter i mean yeah i'll have this
anytime i'll have this any time this one
has some heft to it it's the hot honey
biscuit yeah
a little chicken on there yep
i really like that
this is the special chicken croissants
so here are our desserts so here we have
melotozo so melotozo are marijuana style
pastries which are popular in rome and
japan as well made with melon bread so
melon bread is a type of sweet japanese
bread which has a sugar cookie crust on
the surface but what's funny is that it
doesn't have a melon flavor at all
at all the reason it's called melon
bread is that it just looks like melon
does it look like melon
it does in japan
and this time first kitchen made of
maritotto using melon bread and
mascarpone cheese whipped cream and it's
called melatozo
so here we have melotozo
tiramisu and melodozo matcha and melody
plain so actually yesterday was my
birthday february 18th hey it's your
birthday happy birthday george
thank you for your message thank you
so this is my birthday present
all right so let's give it a shot
best birthday present ever
itadakimasu
this is so good
i can't stop eating this
so wendy's in japan has a japanese
traditional suite since it has been a
collaboration with first kitchen so we
have shiratama cream zentai
so it has three main ingredients ice
cream and sweet red beans and the
shiratama which is kind of like a mochi
rice cake and my grandma likes this type
of sensai
this is for you my grandma
and also we have
mini pancakes
in the u.s we only have two exclusive
desserts into both cookies that's no
disrespect to cookies cookies are great
but one of those fun like italian ice
cream sandwiches they had anyway you get
two cookies here in the u.s a chocolate
chunk cookie and a sugar cookie
[Music]
our wendy's double burger is 578
calories and 29 percent of your daily
recommended amount and 60 of the
recommended daily sodium our double
burger the dave's double isn't much
better ours is 850 calories and way more
fat over 70 percent
but
less sodium just a bit over half of the
daily amount still
not great make the meal in japan and
that increases the calories to 1089
that's 55 of your daily recommended
calorie intake
and if you make it a combo here we chose
the small and took a few sips that's
440 more calories bringing the total to
1290
or
64.5 percent of your daily allowance in
japan the single menu item with the most
calories is the eight-piece fryer
chicken pack which contains
4018 calories 201 percent of your daily
calories
in the us our single biggest calorie
menu item is the feed the fam deal a fam
yeah right this is all for you it is two
spicy chicken sandwiches two junior
bacon cheeseburgers and for a small
fries
total 2 780 calories which is
139 percent of your daily intake
japan's wendy's doesn't disclose their
ingredients list
why japan
the u.s sure does now is there anything
we should be looking out for
of course there is let's start with
sodium nitrate which is found in the
baconators applewood smoked bacon sodium
nitrate is a chemical that is used to
cure meats and gives meat that appealing
pink color perfect for bacon also get
this it's super toxic it is restricted
for purchase online people have
accidentally eaten too much of it and
died it's also been used in homicides
yikes sodium nitrate is on a list of
japan's designated food additives but
our wendy's gets its bacon imported from
denmark where it isn't bad but being
reduced in use
our american cheese contains lecithin
common emulsifier that according to one
academic a worrisome number of
scientific studies have suggested that
too much of it can promote depression
the pickles contain polysorbate 80 this
is commonly used as an emulsifier in
foods but pickles tends to be used as a
solubilizer not how that's pronounced
sorry which helps other ingredients in
the brine fully dissolve
studies have suggested it can cause
colon cancer in mice
not fantastic there is no info on when
this website of where the pickles come
from but we want to point out that
polysorbate 80 is on japan's list of
designated additives and therefore is
permitted to be used in japan
from calari count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between dominoes in japan and the u.s
this is food wars
[Music]
in japan domino's pizzas come in three
sizes our domino's pizza comes in four
sizes so this one is medium which is cut
into edge slices over here on this end
you got the small that's 10 inch pizza
and here's regular which is also cut
into 8 slices next up is our medium
that's a 12 inch pizza
and this one is large this one is cut
into 12 slices then we move to our large
14 inches
and finally the extra large which is 16
inches
look at all that grease
[Music]
a domino's large plane pizza has a 33
centimeters diameter or an
855.3 square centimeters area and costs
2 000 yen
so breaking the down our pizza is 2.33
yen per square inch or about 2 cents
now take our large this is a 14 inch
pizza also a
35.56 centimeter pizza and it has a
surface area of 993.1
square centimeters that's 1.4 cents per
square inch or 1.62 japanese yen but
what gives you the most food for your
money
so here's a large plain slice with a
pancreas
and here's another with hand toaster
crust let's weigh both right now and see
which is more so first let's weigh
pancreas
51 grams
and hand toast crust
it weighs 49 grams
and we will do the same i want to note
that right now in america you can only
get the pan dominoes and the medium size
same exact experiment only i'm doing two
medium pizzas medium pan slice medium
hand tossed slice so this is the hand
toss
slice
and it weighs
a smidge over 75. we'll go 76. a pan
that goes in there too
110 grams
making the difference
this amount
i'm not doing math
in japan we have seven different crust
options number one we have pan
and number two we have hand tossed
and number three we have ultra crispy
it's like a cracker
number four we have cheese burst where a
string cheese is placed around the edge
of a crust and sprinkled with consomme
parmesan seasoning
number five we have the cheese roll
it's got mozzarella cheese in the crust
and number six we have
melee fillet
or meal foy
in japanese we say miroufi
so this one is mirofi pizza which has
two layers of grass with camembert mixed
cheese in between meal failure
[Music]
french people please correct my
pronunciation
number seven the last one we have the
triple
mil fee it's got three layers of crafts
with cheese in between
wow in the u.s we have only five crust
options i realize there's four pizzas in
front of me let me explain one crust
option you can get here and it's the
small only is the gluten-free crust
i don't know
how bread
is gluten free
but we figured it out
we also have the hand tossed
which is more of a standard pillowy i
mean this right there's like standard
deltas what we think a pizza looks like
this is the pan
look i think that is man that's like
triple the dough thickness good onion
for the pan now you can get this in the
medium only we also have a crunchy thin
crust and we have so many pizzas here to
be honest i don't know which one it is
so when it just comes up in the video
i'll show it off but imagine a crunchy
thin pizza oddly enough we also have
something called the brooklyn style
pizza this is reserved for large and
extra large pizzas only and this is a
brooklyn style right here extra large
obviously isn't crispy because it's
sagging this is really thin
here is everything you can get at the
japanese dominoes that you can not get
in the u.s here's everything you can get
at a us dominoes you cannot get in japan
so everyone look at this
this is a limited time offer pizza
it's called the best 34.
look at this lid
it's disgusting
don't look at me don't look at me
so this one has all 34 domino's toppings
like teriyak chicken mayo spinach tomato
shrimp this is huge
it's like my baby
[Music]
the new yorker style pizza is similar to
the brooklyn xl option you can get in
america but only in japan you can get
the quattro new yorker
it's a 16 inch pizza with each new
yorker topping style covering a quarter
of the pizza so one quarter is pepperoni
and one is cheese and one is pepperoni
and sausage and one is ham and mushroom
so here we have nippon favorite series
nippon or nihong means japan in japanese
so these pizzas feature japanese
ingredients this one charcoal grilled
teriyak chicken it's got teriyaki
chicken
teriyak sauce
spinach
mayonnaise and corn next we have
hokkaido three cheeses so hokkaido is
the northern ireland prefecture in japan
and
it's famous for its cheese it's got
hokkaido gouda cheese hokkaido cheddar
cheese and hokkaido camembert and
celeste asparagus we have spicy mayo and
mochi it's got mochi rice cake and corn
pork sausage and sliced asparagus and
korean seaweed flakes and last one we've
got charcoal grilled beef and spinach
and mushrooms
oh
this beef is so tender
and it's got so much like charcoal
flavor
which makes this amazing i love this
so many exclusive pizzas here at the us
dominoes i don't know where to begin so
i'll just start with this one that i'm
holding this is the
cali chicken bacon ranch i don't know
what makes a california innie or cali
but it definitely has chicken and bacon
and ranch and it's big
thank you very much all right
chicken taco pizza
oh yeah
got taco spices to it good job on this
one next one the cheeseburger pizza um
yeah oh my god
i'm gonna say something crazy this
tastes exactly like a mcdonald's
cheeseburger even has like the oniony
and the ketchupy taste
wow
that is a surprise
i thought this one's gonna be bad it's
actually pretty good the extravaganza
it says pepperoni sausage
ham
mushrooms
black olives green peppers this is the
meatzza which i'm assuming is just
a lot of meat i'm seeing sausage i'm
seeing pepperoni
and maybe hamburger
yeah i'll put this in a good pile i
think with this one philly cheese stick
oh no
in some weird way i'm blaming you for
this
since you handed this to me this is your
fault
this is nightmare
meat somewhere on here
i'm also seeing green peppers
oh look look it's like it's like
look at that it's like stuck to the box
no buffalo chicken okay okay there's
more my speed chicken no not tomato
sauce like a white sauce good call
this isn't buffalo enough the capital of
the great state of new york needs to be
better represented in this pizza the
capital of new york is buffalo correct
no
we got the memphis barbecue chicken love
memphis love barbecue love chicken
yeah
the key thing here is the barbecue sauce
i don't know what is in it but man
that's really good
memphis
capital the great state of tennessee
everyone
here is the ultra cheese new yorker
it's got one kilogram of cheese or 2.2
pounds omg
look how thick this cheese is go
go home
it weighs 180 grams
180 times eight equals one thousand four
hundred forty grams in total
so here are other japanese specialty
pizzas so here we have cuatro meat macs
cisco charcoal grilled teriyak chicken
and charcoal grilled beef and giga meat
and gorilla galbi it's like korean style
like beef pizza and next we have seafood
special
this part and this part is shrimp
mayonnaise
so this part it's got shrimp octopus
mussels little neck clams mature clumps
green peppers and cherry tomatoes next
we've got garlic master
looks so spicy garlic and pork sausage
and pancetta and this part it's got
jalapeno obviously it's picante
pepperoni
and italian sausage and onions and look
at this huge thing
mayo jaga
so jaga or jagaimo means potato in
japanese
it's got potato and pork sausage and a
lot of mayo our us domino's have
sandwiches and pasta i was not a fan of
the philly cheesesteak pizza but let's
see what the philly cheesesteak tastes
like in
its native form of sandwich
better than the pizza also the us
dominoes you can get a buffalo chicken
sandwich a chicken habanero sandwich the
mediterranean veggie no thanks a chicken
bacon ranch an italian sandwich and of
course the chicken parm sandwich our
domino's has four pastas to choose from
i only got two the chicken alfredo and
the italian sausage marinara you can
also get a chicken carbonara and a pasta
primavera
i've just been informed i have to eat
this
strong flavor on this i would skip the
pasta
at domino's personally
but this thing is like baked i don't see
how big this is like come on like chef
ramsay here just back oh come on
oh it's just baked on here in the us we
have a few chicken options you can't get
in japan yes japan has wings but they
don't have these flavors visually i can
see why
first flavor we got here
is the garlic parmesan
hey domino's
what are you doing next one we got i'm
assuming this is the
honey barbecue but these drizzles what
are you guys doing drizzling man just
toss it
toss it in the sauce nobody wants a
drizzle
oh wait a second
this is a sweet mango habanero i wasn't
expecting that heat
[Music]
oh man
very good these
are
why did you do this why did you do this
toss it in the sauce why'd you squirt it
on here like as an afterthought honey
barbecue right is this not nuts this is
nuts right they did it like this
i like a far
so domino's also does their wings in
boneless flavors they have obviously
those three and you can also get these
two other ones and i see we have a
crispy bacon and tomato and this one
must be the spicy jalapeno pineapple
whoa what
hell yeah all right
get that b real fast there it go
i know
you're you're
your audible gasps are warranted i don't
know what this
what am i supposed to do with this
oh that's what i'm looking forward to
yuli
we got the food less than an hour ago
i don't think an hour
was unrealistic for food to sit i think
you guys got to put some more chemicals
in your cheese to keep it goopy or
longer oh i got some pineapple and i got
some jalapeno and i got some chicken
let's check it out
yeah
overall
everything here tastes pretty good
presentation you got to work on that in
japan we don't have boneless wings but
we have japanese fried chicken which is
called karage it kind of looks like
american boneless wings
i love karage and also we have
chicken nuggets
both come in 4 8 and 12 pieces our
dominoes has breads and oven baked dips
let's review the breads first shall we
over here we have parmesan bread twists
and garlic bread twists i know that
because of their totally twisted shapes
they also have parmesan bread bites that
were currently unavailable
whoa
oh
these are very good
to parmesan we go
that is that's good but still pretty
good
i mean it's bread and cheese and oil
right us diamond also has something
called stuffed cheesy bread
you can hear stuffed cheesy bread with
either spinach and veta or bacon and
jalapenos take a while to guess which
one i chose
just ripping this whole thing apart oh
god
this thing is especially greasy
for whatever reason
ah dominoes didn't stop there domino's
has something called dips
what it appears to be
is a giant dish of melted cheese and you
can get it in cheesy marinara or five
cheese what are we doing dominoes
what is this
come on guys
so this is the marinara one i'm assuming
a pizza without the bread
right this these dips are literally
zapping my will to live
this please don't ever get
that's a whole bowl of cheese yuli
why would oh look at the oil in this too
everyone in here just gagged
can i even dip it
oh whoa
i don't know what of the five jesus is
in here like which five
[Music]
so here are our japanese exclusive side
menu items let's start with this one
we've got
oven baked potato wedges
this one is plain
consomme
chili garlic
and this one is butter
and next we have
cheese sticks
shrimp popcorn
it comes with this powder sauce here we
have
choregi salad we've got korean style
uh seaweed flakes and thready dores
singh
so troy is like korean style like sesame
oil dressing
and
fresh salad
in the package
so here we have
corn potage
clam chowder minestrone black chili
you've seen these before it is the
domino's marbled cookie brownies
liquid sugar oh yeah
you can also get these cinnamon bread
twists lastly
another dip i swear to god
if there's cheese in this i'm walking
out of here and i'm never coming back
baked apple dips and i'm assuming you
dip these into this
i'm not gonna
so here are other desserts we have mini
pancakes
heart-shaped fonda chocolate
and here we have
egg custard tart
i've never tried this one before
this is so good
so flaky
this one is apple pie
and next we have custard high
lastly
of the sodas you can get in the u.s
can't get in japan get yourself fanta
orange and sprites
we have
coke
zero it's supposed to be zero but they
gave us just normal coke next we have
ginger ale
canada dry canada is an amazing country
a
cool orange juice
and here is soul gambija it's like
japanese blended tea
and last one we've got
georgia japan
craft cafe latte
georgia japan
sounds like george japan
i'd like to be sponsored by you let me
try this
it's got a lot of milk
and sugar in it i gotta be honest
it's not my taste
[Laughter]
take two
i really love this
please give me a sponsorship
[Music]
a japan large hana toaster pizza is 130
calories per slice or 1 560 calories for
the full pizza
in the u.s a large hand tossed pizza
slice is 280 calories which makes the
entire pizza 2
240 calories a large big pepperoni handy
toast slice is 335 calories per slice or
4 020 calories for the entire pizza our
large pepperoni is 370 calories per
slice which makes the entire pie 2
960 calories japan's most calorific
pizza is the ultra cheese new yorker
size one slice is
478 calories that's
3827 for the full pizza
our us dominance pizza with the most
calories is the cali chicken bacon ranch
this is an xl of said pizza one slice is
560 calories and that makes the full pie
3
360 calories
our allergy plan pizza has 1 620
calories total our large cheese is 2 240
calories that's a 38.2
increase our large big pepperoni is
2680 calories over 34 of your daily
recommended calorie intake
333 of your daily sodium
too many tasty calories ours is 2 960
calories 48
over your daily recommended amounts but
somehow ours has less sodium only
299
of your daily sodium
in october of last year a study found
detectable amounts of phthalates a
plastic softener and common menu items
from large fast food chains including
dominoes
the study analyzed 64 food samples from
several popular fast food chains and
found
phthalites
dnbp and dehp in a majority of the items
usa today reported that food containing
meat such as chicken burritos and
cheeseburgers had higher levels of the
chemical study while cheese pizza had
the lowest levels okay so that's good
news for dominoes i guess the study goes
on to say that food handling gloves
contain replacement plasticizers which
may be the source of food contamination
sounds to me like an easy fix just
prepare the food without gloves
japan has a ban on dehp in food handling
gloves
gooder news if you're a fan of food wars
and saw the us versus uk domino's
episode we highlighted bha and bht in
the u.s pepperoni
well on the stewardship page on domino's
website they have stated
we have eliminated a long list of
ingredients from all of our core
products including bha and bht and phos
as well as trans fats from core pizza
products which is fantastic news i
clearly was going to eat it anyway but
thank you regardless
from caloric onto portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between pocky in japan and legos this is
food words
[Music]
in japan our pocky comes in a 72 gram
box which contains two pockets
and a online pack
our pockets come in basically three
sizes the 1.14 ounce box the 2.47 ounce
box and the 4.13
ounce
boxy bag but our strawberry flavored box
is smaller than this chocolate box this
is a 3.81 ounce box which is .32 ounces
smaller than this one largest box bag is
this the cookies and cream flavor which
is 4.5
ounces or .44 grams larger than the
chocolate box one theory my theory is
that the pocky boxes contain a specific
number of pocky sticks and each pocky is
a different weight based on the flavor
coating so we're going to weigh each
pocky individually to see if this is
true
all right chocolate first
so seven of these
are 13 grams can someone write that down
strawberry 7 is
13 grams
was that what the first one was okay
cookies and cream
cookies and cream seven of them are 18
grams well the cookies and cream ones
are definitely a lot heavier a lot
heavier
mmm
so let's see how many pocky are in a box
itch
nip
some
[Music]
32 33 34
34 pocky in total so one pocket has 17
pocky and another one also has seventy
pocky let's see how many pockies are in
this box
oh man
is this normal
i think i can cut him like do you want
to get like a close-up on on there
before so one two three those are broken
ones
30 31 32 33 34 35 36
you know how everyone was complaining
about how i eat kitkats in the kitkat
episode
here's all the pockies that are native
to the us that are not in japan
and here are all the pakis native to
japan cookies and cream
cookies and cream not a solid block so
that's
good yeah
yeah
yeah
i like those this looks like fun julie
chocolate banana have you had these
before
you have
yeah mm-hmm
that banana flavor hits like right away
oh no
much of green tea any food wars heads
watching now
joe does not like matcha
smells like a freshly cut lawn
yeah yeah
there's also a crunchy strawberry flavor
you can get here in the u.s but i was
not able to get my hands on it by the
time of filming this episode
so here's this regular strawberry
oh
oh another
salad block
mmm well good
put me in jail for crimes against
monkeys
george's energy
let's go
all right let's start with this one we
have pocky luxury milk chocolate
is it pocky
you look like corn dog
what happened to you
it's got milk
and fermented butter flavor
and we have another corn dog it's an
almond milk flavor
yes strong almond milk flavor
i prefer this one
the milk chocolate but both are so short
you should be longer
you do
we have
this ultra thin pocky
oh
you're so thin
this time
this one is short
this part is so thin
we have
tasty
why is it tasty oh
fermented butter is used for this stick
it's got just a little bit of
butter flavor
i still prefer this one
this corn look
i'm on the crush
it's a little bit different look at the
pockets
yeah obviously it's got almonds okie
i love this
i love this
we've got hockey chocolate coconut
oh this one is also
this style of pockets
oh
it's pretty similar with this one i'm on
the crush
yeah obviously it's got coconut flavor
and also it's got a little bit of
saltiness it's not my taste
strawberry chocolate pocky
ah
right after you bite this you get some
sweetness but after that you get
sourness it smells so strong
i can smell it from here
coco powder pocky
and it says you can only get this in
winter season oh yeah look at this it's
got cocoa powder
oil
we've got the cutest pocky ever
cherry heart-shaped hockey
oh look at this
heart is in there how cute
and this part cherry chocolate is so
awesome
you get strong cherry flavor
we've also got blueberry heart-shaped
chocolate pocky
ooh
look at this
so blue
this color doesn't make me want to eat
this
but let's try
it
[Music]
so sour but look at this heart-shaped
pocky
not for me
this is what i've been waiting for
sakura matcha
osakura means cherry blossom
cherry blossom much a taste
look at this
so it's got matcha chocolate and this
stick is
pink
this is so japanese pocky just sweet
matcha the feeling of spring has come to
my life
spring is here in my body
[Music]
and everybody is curious what these are
mega minoru
what does it mean
i don't even know
anyway so it says mega mino ruby it
means like goddess
ruby
in english it says amber kind of like
stone fossil jewel
it says it goes well with red wine
interesting
it looks like regular chocolate pocky
oh
what is this
this test itself is like berries this
one goes well with whiskey
it's pretty close to dark chocolate it's
bitter in japan we have this kokubo so
extra fine pocky which are roughly half
the thickness of a regular chocolate
pocky and in the u.s ours are called the
ultraslum
i got a new digital scale what i'm gonna
do is weigh a regular chocolate pocky
2.13 grams
so i'll draw thin hockey so it weighs
1.52 grams
thinner
that's it here's the big boy
here's the thing
is it is able to do this okay like get
out of the way so it's just the white
background 23 24 25 and there's another
bag in here so 50 per box
okay so 50 instead of 36 seven regular
pockies are 13 grams let's see how many
slim ones we need to get to 13 grams
five six seven
eight and a half eight and a half slim
ones are the same as seven regular ones
is that that much slimmer i guess that's
slimmer does anyone else think that
that's like not significant enough to be
a selling point
pocky adjusts its sweetness for
different countries not surprisingly the
us ones are meant to be sweeter i'm
going to do a taste test side by side
they got the american ones hear the
japanese one and we're going to see just
how different they taste i'm worried
that these are also going to be a
a pocky popsicle oh no okay
japanese these are the only japanese
ones i could find obviously they're
bigger i don't know if this is the norm
in the baseline sweeteners
yeah
um
yeah it's noticeably different
they taste identical
but ours has
like a sweet aftertaste
i like i like the japanese one's much
better
sapaki is in the guinness world records
three times it's the largest chocolate
coated biscuits brand has the most
mentions of a brand name on twitter in
24 hours which was
3710 0044 times and finally was part of
the most people opening packaged food
online simultaneously with 143 people
143 people that's it that doesn't seem
like that many i feel like i've been on
zoom work calls with 143 people in it
right
it would have been literally one email
to set that up i can do
kakib
[Laughter]
now i got more than 200 versus clowns
right here
simultaneously three two one
[Applause]
now i broke the guinness world records
so november 11th is known as apokki nohi
or pokiday in japan
this date was chosen because a [ __ ] is
shaped like a 1 and november 11th
visually looks like for pocky
and also pets are included in this day
november 11th which is the pretzel
version of pocky and in japan you can
get them in flavors like salad ripe
tomato sweet potato and
roasted bread flavor
in the u.s we also have pratts and we
get these fun flavors like sweet corn
fun
and
pizza oh god
there's nothing on it
nope
i mean yeah it tastes like
corn
why though what is the demand for corn
flavored
sticks
besides pizza anything flavored like
pizza is terrible even pizza combos
aren't very good
no
i mean it's up there with like croutons
does anyone grab a hand full of croutons
on the go and we're just eating a box of
croutons like these probably would be
good on something
in japan our chocolate pocky box for 100
grams has 506 calories adjusted for the
box size 72 grams the package contains
364
calories
and let's break it down even further to
per pocky one pokey contains on average
11.38 calories
a us chocolate pocky box contains 340
calories just a little bit less than a
japanese box but note there is a two
gram difference now here at food wars we
thrive on scientific accuracy so let's
break it down per pocky one u.s pocky is
nine point four four four four four four
four
four four four four four four four four
four four four four four four calories
the highest calorie pack in japan is to
be determined we email the customer
service but we didn't get their response
they're doing hurry up but i guess the
spocky
is the most calorific pocky it's
196 calories
so should be because it's got a lot of
butter in it
the u.s pocky with the most calories is
the cookies and cream it contains total
630 calories there's no question i can
murder this whole box in one setting 630
calories that's nothing that's that's
like kind of reassuring like wow only
630 thoma breakfast
[Music]
japan pokey contains these ingredients
wheat flour sugar cacao mess vegetable
oils whole milk powder shortening malt
extract starch salt yeast cocoa powder
butter emulsifier flavoring leavening
agent anato coloring and mineral salt
any us pocket contains wheat flour sugar
chocolate liqueur blend of vegetable
oils that blend being sunflower oil palm
oil whole milk powder vegetable oil
shortening which is palm oil
hydrogenated palm oil cocoa butter salt
artificial flavors yeast soy lecithin
leavings sodium bicarbonate mono and
diglycerides of fatty acids wink
in japan our pocky contains mild extract
which is sometimes used as a replacement
for sugar in baking it contains lots of
maltose a type of sugar which actually
has a higher glycemic index value than
normal sucrose so it's a surprise that
american pocky are supposed to be
sweeter
there are actually differences in the
types of cocoa used if you've watched
the us vs uk snickers episode you know
that american chocolate
isn't that so great in the us our
pockets are made with chocolate liqueur
and cocoa butter chocolate liqueur is
just cocoa that's been processed into
semi-solid form and is actually around
50
cocoa butter itself the trouble is for
an american product to be classified as
milk chocolate only needs to contain
around 10 percent of chocolate liqueur
and the rest can be made up of sugars
and various ingredients
in japan the rules are different
depending on the type of product milk
chocolate material must contain at least
21
cocoa content double the required amount
in america so our chocolate has more
chocolate are you jealous of us
come to japan
from caloric onto portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between 7-11 and japan and the u.s this
is food wars
in japan our coffee is coming
medium and large
and extra-large
if you're getting coffee why not grab a
chocolate donut
our 7-eleven drinks come in sizes of 200
milliliters 450 milliliters and 1 liter
and 1.5 liters i'm sorry i couldn't get
it
in the us we have big gulps self-service
fountain drink four sodas and they come
in these four sizes medium large extra
large double extra loud
so i want to see how much the biggest
size cup i could get at the 711 is and
to do that i will need hang on
just past 40.
it's exactly 48 ounces that's hardly
double extra i'll round it up because of
this section here i'll round it up to
50. 711 also at one point
offered a size that was even bigger
called the team gulp which again
according to them was 128
fluid ounces for
your team
because who doesn't like to after a
softball game go to 7-eleven get a team
gulp and 10 straws you know just kick it
with the with the boys right come on
team yeah right that's for one person
don't be ridiculous
[Music]
here are many many many
7-eleven items you can get in the u.s
you can't get in japan and here are many
of the 7-eleven items exclusive to japan
japan puts the convenience in the
convenience store we call it konbini
which is the abbreviation of the
convenience store and it makes our life
a lot easier for example office workers
rely on stores like 7-eleven for food
and drink to keep them happy so that
they can be productive at work
and for students they tend to buy juices
and snacks and hot foods and instant
noodles you know and when i was a kid i
would often eat like hot foods and
instant noodles with my friends
and with my ex-girlfriends
7-eleven memories
i studio
[Music]
and for families there's pretty much
every daily essentials they may need and
also you can pay your bills get ticket
reservations for music and sports 711
even has its own bank and atms
no matter where you go especially in big
cities like tokyo you can find more than
one company on every block
yeah it's a bit different here in the
u.s i do frequent 7-eleven and it's not
bad but the vibe is more kind of like
get the thing you need and go uh the
food is usually pretty hit or miss
usually missed in my experience uh the
hot food looks like it's been sitting up
for a while so i usually don't get it
since there are way too many items
exclusive to japan for us to buy for one
episode so i've curated some of my
favorites for you guys this is still a
ton of food so here we have japanese
onigiris
this one is plum
tuna mayonnaise shrimp and mayonnaise
mentaiko which is spicy cut raw i picked
these onigiris from the back because
onigiri in the back are fresh
of all time and let me show you how to
open this one just put this over
to
here
like this
so that you can have the dried you know
seaweed
a little bit sweet a little bit of sour
so here is our sushi
look at this huge salmon sushi
gorgeous
gorgeous sushi itadakimasu oh my god
this is so delicious
[Music]
we got this long
natto roll
personally i love natto but even
japanese people
fifty percent of them
like it fifty percent of them don't like
it this is an acquired taste
i stood
so after this sticky and smelly natural
i've got sushi roll special package
so when it comes to this one it's called
oina di-san it has rice inside and the
skin is like a sweet tough skin
[Music]
this is so good
so like my grandma always cook this for
me and this makes me happy all the time
and next to orinarisam
this like gorgeous sushi roll it's like
japanese version of california roll
[Music]
one thousand percent better than
california
kampio maki
in english it's like dried gourd roll
perfect sushi roll a last one we have
pickles radish pickles it's quite yellow
it definitely has yellow number five
itadakimasu
i'm gonna give them
grammy award
understanding our vision
ah the hot food is a 7-eleven in the us
we got a lot of options not as many as
japan i'm not quite sure what some of
this stuff is just by looking at it so
let me go down the list nachos they're
the self-service nachos so they have the
chips ready to go and then you just open
them up and add cheese and chili onto
them
oh no thank you over here these mini
tacos man it's like really
like
what about my face
oh man they've been sitting for a while
so don't forget them we also have wings
crispy and
not so crispy i could bean burrito guy
over here in the roller taquito section
you can get a barbecue bacon
cheeseburger roller spicy garlic roller
regular taquito korean bbq taquito also
we have chicken sandwiches a black bean
burger glazed cheesy barbecue meatballs
also at our 7-elevens you get pepperoni
pizza cheese or seven meats and also for
hot dogs we got an exclusive hot picante
dog no one so here are our hot food
sections we've got steamed buns
it's got pork and bamboo shoots and this
is really standard like nikuma so next
size up we have the doubled nikuma
and next one this little guy
what is this
sweet beans skimmed one and last steamed
bun is
pizza bun
you really are the pizza
[Music]
delicious so all these things like um
around 100 yen to 200 yen or so so
if you're broke you should definitely
try this
we've got
these ones
this one is called cut it
it's like deep fried
curry bread how about you i want to eat
this
i want to eat this right now itadakimasu
holy moly um it's freaking delicious
and next one crockett it's basically got
potato and pork means
the last hot food we've got is corn dog
so this one right here it's pretty
japanese one it's got ketchup and a
monster and you just squeeze this one
onto this one all right let's go let's
go let's go let's go let's go
in japan we have these chicken options
first i'm gonna start with this one
karage bowl
so in japan when you make japanese fried
chicken you put some soy sauce on it so
it has soy sauce flavor and also garlic
flavor
so freaky
delicious so this karaoke boy's got
one two
three
and four caracas
we have
fried chicken
spicy fried chicken chicken nuggets
hot sandwich the buffalo style chicken
slider the cheeseburger and the
bacon cheeseburger i mean can you even
tell which ones
right which one
huh
i'm assuming avisa's burger's been
cooked
more on this in the ingredient section
uh 7-eleven in the u.s
anything probably here in southern
california has tacos and burritos get
yourself a chicken fajita taco
al pastor taco i thought this was good
and a chorizo breakfast taco the spicy
beef bean and cheese burrito this ain't
any burrito baby it's the bomb
bombing off the toilet good god you're
getting this and you're microwaving it
there so if you're like walking out to
7-eleven shopping on the bomb like
better make it home in time because oh
man it's coming empanadas right
i'm gonna go ahead and put this in here
and i close the lid like it's a coffin
go away forever all right so here are my
favorite bentos let's take a look at
this one it's called nori bento
this one is pretty popular one in japan
so it's got crockett a deep fried fish
cake fried fish with tartar sauce kim
piragu is like japanese traditional
salad pickles and as you can see right
here it's got spicy cottage bowl
under this seaweed it's got rice
and fish flakes
i love this pencil like when i was a
student i think i would eat this every
single day so after my favorite one
this one look at this so this one is a
korean style beef bento
oh man it smells so good
whoa
everything right here is
so amazing fantastic this is so
mushy soyo
tonkatsu
and it comes with this sauce for this
tonkatsu look how thick it is so outside
from bentos we have soba
soba noodle
put this sauce first
put wasabi
and dry the seaweed
and then you put water onto soba noodle
it's getting moist
and don't forget to put green onions
right here
itadakimasu so you could soak a noodle
in this box
i guarantee you can't stop eating this
because it's so delicious
sorry i still love noodles because
japanese people or asian people do make
noises when you eat noodles we slurp
slurp slurp right now
they got the meals over there in japan
we got meals too like this ready-made
ricotta romano parmesan cheese stuffed
ravioli topped with marinara sauce much
just stop stop doing this stop please
stop
oh then so then it's like japanese
traditional hot pot it's got a fish cake
fried tofu noodle thing this is made
from potato egg
radish in winter when you eat this
this warms you up from your heart
to your body and next
graten doria so obviously it's got meat
sauce and a lot of cheese under this
cheese it's got a lot of rice in there
it's like japanese western food we have
seven premium main dishes
naan and butter chicken curry and next
we have seven premium side dishes
mackerel grilled mackerel we also have
mackerel in miso
zaba miso
is smoked tongue in japan it's pretty
popular item especially when you go to
like a japanese barbecue restaurant we
ordered the like beef tongue or pig tang
so this one used to be like this
smells so good so fancy
[Music]
it's marvelous so after this sexy tongue
we have sexy
fish cake
and look at this bar
it's a chicken bar so it's like a
chicken nugget before it's fried octopus
and wasabi this is just raw octopus kim
piragobo it's a sauteed bird dog
fijikini stewed hijiki seaweed and
potato salad so like when i go home my
mom always cooks like this one this one
this one i love you mom
i miss mom's cooking
and next we have premium gold main
dishes shrimp with chili sauce beef stew
hamburg steak
sandwiches 7-eleven egg salad peanut
butter and jelly turkey and cheddar
cheese on a kaiser roll so we have the
italian style
sub but then we also got
the italian job
turkey and ham with is that cheese in
the picture there we got the smoked
turkey and monterey jack cheese sandwich
and they separated the lettuce so you
had it like rightfully ready to eat so
it's still nice and crisp salads chicken
caesar salad we also have a pepperoni
pasta salad so here are my favorite
sandwiches it's got tuna right here and
a cheese and lettuce and the rest of
these are ham and egg
i thought this is normal but you don't
have this one
fruit sandwich
it's got a whole bunch of fruits it's
got peach pineapples and oranges
whipped cream so it's like cake so here
is seven premium drip coffee so i'm
gonna make myself a cup of coffee
and it just sits on here
all right
[Music]
it tastes like
so for breakfast sandwiches at 7-eleven
you can get yourself a
croissant with ham mac and cheese
ooh an english muffin with bacon egg and
cheese we also have english muffins with
sausage egg and cheese sausage biscuits
and sausage egg and cheese croissants
the 7-eleven signature brand also has
mini donuts chocolate cinnamon crunch
and of course powdered madeline's
7-eleven is cookies right the register
for a dollar you can get yourself some
macadamia nut cookies oatmeal raisin
sugar but there's also chocolate chip
cookie one uh baked goods you get
yourself some muffins there's a
blueberry muffin coffee cake crispy rice
treat bar nonsense rice crispy because
you know that's copyrighted walnut fudge
brownie bear claw danish iced honey bun
cheese danish mixed berry danish glazed
honey bun look at these pre-packaged it
says flavored snack pie it's a weird way
of putting it lemon
key lime banana cream i feel like they
used the same that's the same as
photoshop right there buddy boston green
apple
and the last one strawberry cheesecake
key lime
ah
it's key limey oh yeah oatmeal that's
obviously maple syrup right there but
the first thing i did when i looked at i
was like wait does it have brandy in it
who's the oatmeal you can put hot water
in here joe or hot milk huli
or
hot whiskey your boss won't notice the
difference
well at first
here we have japanese type of bread
stir-fried noodles and sauce bread we
call it yakisoba pan
now you may be thinking what that
is this
so it's like hot dog but
instead of sausage we got
stair fried noodle inside
carb
carb
it makes you fat bread makes you fat so
kids love this noodle and bread
itadakimasu
this one reminds me of my childhood me
playing tags in the mountain and chasing
the girls
now a lot of girls are chasing me
this is a crab thread it's got two
crab shaped bread now the question is
does it taste like crab
it doesn't taste like crab tastes like
just bread
pink bread it's a cherry blossom
flavored called dink bread
this pink stuff is it's pretty sour
tastes like cherry blossom and like my
first kiss
this is the
salty savory snack zone ah so much stuff
and i've hit the food wars wall hot and
spicy crackling curls the original and
the fried pork rinds chili lime
i'm not tasting anything pork related to
it a little pig guy there
little pig again you're on the menu
buddy next seven selects has their own
veggie straws
this will be the trail mix and mix like
section we got these uh cheese pizza
flavored snack mix
stinky boy if you have a bunch of these
yeah we got the spicy ranch flavor mix
and this last one just sesame sticks for
those of you who like to uh get your
trail mix or your chex mix and then
unmix them and organize them anything
like that 7-eleven it's got a snack for
you oh this is kind of a party snack mix
this is what i would totally get yogurt
yogurt pretzels like with yogurt on
there like you're thinking oh yogurt
that's healthy right it's just it's the
same as icing now you're looking at this
going jack links beef jerky that's not a
7-eleven brand no it's not but as you
can see exclusive 7-eleven flavors see
this was like hey jack links guess what
we're about to push you out on the [ __ ]
on our shelf space so do a deal with us
you're gone completely and jack winks
was like no i got kids to pig please
brown sugar bourbon
original recipe original
hickory smoked bacon like snacking on
cheese and nothing else full house baby
this one is mozzarella cheese wrapped in
hard salami pepper jack stick gouda
cheese to go oh the big one the big
cheese the white cheddar this ain't your
grandma's cheese it's the big one
just two cheddar cheese
colby jack which is like camouflage
cheese
pretzels
mini twists non-yogurted pretzel nuggets
oh gross this one's a peanut butter
inside of them pretzel sticks i feel
like there was a while there in the
early 90s when they were like chips are
bad for you eat pretzels instead these
are really salty too a serving size of
these is three i would get this assume
i'm gonna sit and eat this whole bag in
one sitting i'm not gonna do three at a
time the whole bag is 1160 milligrams 50
of your sodium intake mini rice cakes
chips 7-eleven has a bunch of their own
potato chips including the original
fiery hot kettle chips which are way
better than regular chips again spicy
jalapeno smoked gouda ooh buddha
barbecue
salt and pepper ruffles rip-offs we got
cheddar and sour cream prime rib i'm
trying these and buffalo chicken dip
prime rib oh it smells terrible
oh my god oh so bad it's definitely not
this
i have more like ground beef instead of
one of these like fancy forks it'd be
like a the plastic spork that they have
at 7-eleven they're opening the bag with
the spork meats pouring out of it on the
floor of a 7-eleven with a guy mopping
around it
nuts baby nuts
the rise and shine fiber blend of a
trail mix whatever antioxidants yeah
rights
revive and thrive auntie another
antioxidant mix should have just should
just handed these out during coven but
it bounced back in a week cashew halves
you like your nuts halved oh yeah you
like like nuts hold booyah doesn't
matter if they're whole or not that
would that affect the flavor at all who
cares spicy ranch
pistachios
and of course jumbo flavored
wasabi and soy nuts nope wasabi will
never touch my lips again after that
video so here are my favorite instant
noodles let's start ippudo ramen man i
love this so it's got some pockets a
dried
pork it's a miso for the ramen soup
dried veggies
and it's got noodles
[Music]
all right
and you gotta wait for three minutes so
while i'm waiting for this i'm gonna go
this one so it's called
champ
so it basically is a yak soba it's
always like a japanese stair fried
noodles
so you put some hot water
onto this line
alright so it's been three minutes put
the soup
into this bowl
mix it
slow song
[Music]
bravo
so epidural has a lot of locations in
japan including tokyo but this taste
this flavor is totally the same as the
restaurants serving so
just get it at 7-eleven
i've totally forgot that oh
so i put some hot water but oh
i should have thrown the water away into
the toilet
noodles let's make yakisoba
the volume of these noodles
gets a lot bigger
okay so put yakisoba sauce
and flakes
and most importantly mayo
mayo beam
and mix it up
so this is yakisoba
like we usually eat this like at like
summer
festival pretty good as always next we
have takomeshi
look at this it's got a green onions
and i believe this is taco
[Applause]
so three minutes again
look at this final
noodle it says
ultra
spicy final you're gonna be crying
because of the spiciness it's too spicy
but i'm gonna try this
only for a shooting purpose this is for
you guys we can't do it
oh man
i'm so scared
all right so i think it's time to eat
this one so i'm gonna throw the water
away in the toilet again
let's go to the toilet
and put yakisoba sauce
already
the test itself is lighter than this one
i prefer this one
but
but
this is the kink ramen
all right so
finally let's make
the freaking spicy noodle i call it
death
in case i'm dead
please find another japanese host
it was nice to meet you foot insider
cool
oh man look at this
it's not red
it's blood how do i need this
[Music]
this is for you guys
[Music]
[Music]
am i alive
am i not dead
i'm in heaven
hell
i feel like i'm in hell
it's not all junk food at the 7-eleven
joe and yuli they also have delicious
freshly sliced fruits prepackaged and
everything came straight from the ground
and it comes in a container that will be
here
until the sun explodes this i mean this
has to be an la thing you can get mango
with tahini and seasoning
fantastic combination finally grape cup
7-eleven also has his own brand of
packaged candies
sour gummy bears
sour neon gummy worms
sour watermelon wedges green apple rings
gummy worms
for catching gummy fish
i like that fruit leather whatever we
call this chili mango hell yeah i'm
trying these sweetened mango and a
sweetened fruit medley
not bad ah a little spicier than i
thought well it's also gummy bears and
gummy sharks it's also gummy peach rings
they got jelly beans and they got sour
cherries
7-eleven selects in the u.s also has
their own
line of
sandwich cookies vanilla
pumpkin spice
double chocolate peppermint s'mores the
duplexes lemon cream
so here are japanese sweets pink rice
cake with red bean paste
so basically uh it's like curry blossom
mochi itadakimasu
mmm
i want to eat this under the tree of
cherry blossom
[Music]
cherry blossom
[Music]
next we have
ninja gummy he's like ninja salary
so it's a hard gummy
it's really tough
like stones
it's like pocky but like the chocolate
is inside
i'm loving it look at this cute guy
koala no
koalas marriage chocolate
my favorite would be this one
when i was a kid i would eat this every
single day and this taste is so
nostalgic
a little george is calling me like
hey i need this i hey we're filming
right now later after shooting okay
okay okay
we're good
pretty
please prepare the plate and you just do
like this
one two three
go
this shape is like cherry blossom look
how jelly it is
[Music]
this is the best pudding ever we had to
go on a run to get more stuff that's why
visually this all doesn't connect seven
mom's got macaroons french macaroons
mini cheesecakes
new york style and strawberry swirl
these i can get behind our 7-eleven in
the us has ice cream such as banana
cream pie caramel butter pecan chocolate
covered strawberry double cookie dough
cookies and cream sea salt caramel
strawberry banana shortcake so let's
start with cold stuff we've got fried
dumplings
it's frozen frozen takoyaki
frozen fried rice
so after these frozen meals
i got ice cream
choco monaka jumbo
is like japanese ice cream sandwich
inside
let me buy it
sorry it looks gross
it's got ice cream and it's got
chocolate in the middle and uh this
crunchy on the outside every japanese
people get this one at least once in
their life and last ice cream i got this
one gorilla chocolate ice cream i don't
know what this is
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry
this is delicious
not only me but
gorilla would love this a lot of
exclusive drinks uh i don't know where
to begin so i kind of lined them up by
perception of healthiness
so all the way down on this end we've
got 7-eleven select go smart cold
organic pressed juices
this one's the tropical glow and this
gross looking one is of course clean and
green
after that we got these pre-packaged
juices these are the seven select
farmer's grove cranberry cocktail
raspberry lemonade orange juice of
course regular lemonade and next up in
the bigger ones we have the 711
teas peach black tea
sweet tea they weren't kidding me look
at that lemon sweet tea and
green tea fruit punch mango
guava energy
come on
herbal tonic herbal desserble guys yeah
7-eleven also has their own brand of are
these
energy drinks the gatorades and
powerades and the like replenish and of
course replenish zero i'm assuming zero
added sugar orange mango fruit punch
lemonade the cherry is clear
what why is cherry clear guava splash
orange mango these are bad 7-eleven
energy
strawberry lemonade energy shot one and
a half times with caffeine of a cup of
coffee oh good god
undrinkable how bad is that the taste
where this is too i can get to this
you've seen the show right you'll see
what i'll tolerate this i can barely
tolerate this
here's something that they don't have
in japan don't have slurpees that's nuts
right slurpees are how do you describe a
slurpee it's like a flavored slush
uh we have endless slurpee flavors the
ones currently you can get here in
america are blue rocketberry blood
orange vitamin water xxx blue raspberry
blueberry lemonade bliss cherry
coca-cola mountain dew citrus peach
perfect pina colada and pineapple whip
so here are japanese exclusive drinks we
have vegetable juice of course
we see a lot of japanese salarymen drink
this one every morning to get their day
started so this one is for joe joe
you're missing a lot of veggies so you
should drink this one
my favorite green tea and these two are
hot drinks black coffee and coffee latte
and this is our first time filming this
we have alcohol we have seven premium
beer
and this one is not beer it's like
sprite with alcohol it contains nine
percent of alcohol it's pretty delicious
but at the same time it's pretty
dangerous japanese sake
when you come to japan you can see a lot
of people drinking alcohol outside they
were like
they're not dead
they're just living they're drunk
whiskey
7-eleven in the u.s has his own private
brand wines yosemite road trojan horse
plot and point and voyager point it also
has its own canned wine brand called
romer
perhaps the reason 711 has such a wide
variety of products in japan is that
it's everywhere in japan
there are 21 215 stores in japan that's
crazy which is nearly 30 of all the 711s
in the world of course all 37
prefectures have a 7-eleven and out of
all of them the city of tokyo has the
most locations with 2 850. to put that
in perspective the u.s has 9417-7111
and there's no 7-elevens in 18 states as
far as states california has the most 1
823
but as far as
denseness in area
las vegas nevada has the most with 158.
[Music]
in japan our hot dog is 290 calories and
720 milligrams of sodium which is 31.3
percent of your daily elements
our hot dog is 180
calories how about this our hot dog is
180 calories but for the frank only the
stats for some reason don't say anything
about the bun but this isn't much better
for you it's 570 milligrams of sodium so
around 24.8 percent of your daily
alliance
japan's handy rolled tuna and mayo
onigiri has 258 calories and it's very
filling remember this guy the tuna
sandwich here in the u.s ours is 420
calories and lots of sodium over 800
milligrams
and in the u.s a super big gulp of
coca-cola this isn't coca-cola it's 44
fluid ounces it's 513 calories and 143
grams of carbs it's over half your daily
intake
[Music]
in japan 7-eleven does not disclose the
ingredients list of especially mad food
items
it does however tell us the country of
origin for the raw materials for certain
items like the fried food yakitori oden
and chinese steamed buns
the chicken for our fried chicken is
from thailand the pork for our sausages
and hot dogs comes from usa canada and
japan the wheat for the buns comes from
canada the usa and japan and asking
beans come from canada cheese comes from
new zealand and the shrimp for the
shrimp chili buns is from vietnam
this is the pepperoni the pizza in the
u.s and it contains all this junk
i mean
what's this thing
never heard of that
what about chicken strips it's got all
this stuff
just like mom used to make
and of course the 7-eleven select
cheeseburger which contains
sesame seed bun has enriched flour
excuse me enriched wheat flour wheat
flour nice and sober taste iron
monocerotidate
serotonin
calcium bony ate as a preservative
calcium sulfate
got smoke flavor added and it's beef
encapsulated salt potatoes anything else
after that salt spice pasteurized
processed cheese they're sitting down
that's how long this is going my camera
person just sat down a preservative
paprika and a nettle color so i guess
the last takeaway from this video is
that in the u.s some of our 7-eleven
items can be a little bit of a gamble
with your health speaking of gambling
you know your boy got some scratchers
when he was over at 7-eleven
okay so there's the winning numbers okay
so we don't win anything on that one
i have no clue how to do this
did i win
if you haven't subscribed yet subscribe
now because we are filming this for 6
hours